現代人願望很多
講個最簡單的
希望每天的生活
白天有說有笑
晚上睡個好覺
結果是呢
晚上肉身不睡
白天精神崩潰
胡乃文開講囉
我是你的老朋友 胡醫師
睡覺是身體恢復
與大腦清除廢物
最有效的方法
尤其是進入熟睡狀態更棒
熟睡時
大腦才會啟動清潔模式
排出廢物
今天要跟你分享三個
幫助熟睡的方法
熟睡的穴位
安眠的食物
以及我已經實踐二十多年
被科學證實有效的
頂級助眠術
失眠按什麼穴位？
手1穴心神就歸位
一個人有兩個我
一個在黑暗中醒著
一個在光明中睡著
還有一個在床上滑手機
滑到凌晨兩點
還不肯睡
如果你是那種
身體已經累爆
腦袋還在嗶嗶叫的人
今晚就試試
這個超實用的安眠穴
這個穴叫做
神門 又稱之為安神穴
是心跟神的重要通道
有寧心安神 舒緩情緒
幫助睡眠之效
哎 水某
神門穴在哪裡 你知道嗎
我知道
在這裡
哇 真棒
你都知道
當然了
真的很棒
我來示範
按穴位的方法
你把手腕橫紋上
在這手腕橫紋
小指跟無名指
之間的這條線上
連到這個橫紋
這個穴就叫做神門穴
這個穴你按下去
有沒有一種
痠痠麻麻的感覺
假如有的話
就是按對了 很棒哦
跟我美麗的太太一樣棒
睡前按壓
左右神門穴
各一兩分鐘
有放鬆的效果
尤其對容易多夢
睡不深的人特別有效
底下進一段廣告
廣告後我就告訴你
讓我熟睡
精神好的大秘訣
這個習慣
讓我夜夜好眠 身體健康
沒有所謂的三高
睡覺就像是
幫大腦清潔
而我們居住的家
也需要常常清掃洗一洗
有一個清潔產品
介紹給你哦
最近小編給我這一瓶
萬能去漬霸
本來只是想說試試看
結果一用
真的有夠讚！
媽媽們應該懂
煎魚
炸排⻣之後
油四處亂噴
瓦斯爐 抽油煙機
都是一層厚厚的油垢
像這種不銹鋼的鍋子
煮的黑黑的
現在
我用這一瓶
萬能去漬霸
噴一噴
等五分鐘後
你用抹布 菜瓜布
刷一刷
去除油垢 焦垢
乾乾淨淨
整個廚房水噹噹！
有一次小編喝咖啡
灑到襯衫
我用這一瓶去漬霸
噴一噴
搓一搓
咖啡漬清乾淨了
有小孩的媽媽
小孩穿的衣服會沾滿
各種彩色筆顏色
沾到醬油
你用這一瓶去漬霸
噴一噴
去除各種色素
它採用美國橘油酵素配方
不刺鼻
無螢光劑
無磷
用得讓人很安心
從廚房
浴室到衣服
這一瓶
三新立潔萬能去漬霸
就能搞定家中大小清潔事
20種助眠食物
提升褪黑激素的分泌
你有這種症狀嗎
晚上晚睡
淺眠睡不好
白天去上班
人在辦公室
卻沒有在辦公事
當薪水的小偷啊
中醫怎麼看睡眠呢
失眠多半都跟
心神不寧 陰血不足有關
想要睡得好
就要讓心神安定
氣血充足
心神不寧的人
吃什麼東西
會比較好睡
中醫常見的助眠食材
百合 清心安神
蓮子 補脾養心
酸棗仁 養肝血 安神定志
搭配小米 黑芝麻 桂圓等等
有補氣血 安五臟的作用
阿嬤媽媽
要去菜市場買菜
可以買什麼
回去煮
要提升褪黑激素
幫助入睡 可以這樣買
蛋白質的來源有
蛋 魚 牛奶
水果裡頭有
葡萄 奇異果 香蕉
堅果類有
核桃 杏仁 黑芝麻
蔬菜可以選
地瓜葉 菠菜
還有番茄等等
這些食物富含色氨酸
鈣 鎂 還有B群
有助於穩定神經
讓你情緒放鬆幫助入睡
頂級助眠術 靜坐
跟大家分享
我和我的美麗的太太
已經實踐二十多年的一個
已被科學實證的
頂級助眠術
叫靜坐
以前緊張
都會睡不好
現在打坐以後
心就穩定
然後呢
就睡得更好
晚上睡覺就
躺下去就會睡著了
對啊 就更好睡了
不像以前這樣睡
都翻來翻去
現在晚上
躺下去了就很好睡
還有睡得比較安穩
起來的時候也不累
感覺很清爽
真的 我也是熟睡後
神清氣爽
靜坐的關鍵
在於它能夠
啟動你的
副交感神經系統
這套系統呢
就像身體的放鬆總司令
能讓你從白天緊繃焦慮的
交感神經的狀態
切換到修復
和休息的這個節奏
你會發現
心跳變慢
血壓下降
呼吸變深
情緒也安定下來
這正是身體
進入休眠的前奏
真的呢
我經常有這種體驗
真的會這樣
許多靜坐練習者
包括我自己
都親身體驗過
入睡更快 睡得更沉
情緒更穩定
焦慮感明顯的減少
有研究早就證實說
靜坐真的有放鬆的效果
像美國伊利諾大學
做過一個實驗
讓受試者
靜坐5到10分鐘
結果發現
他們的大腦的耗氧量
降低了17%
這個變化
跟睡了7個小時差不多
而且血液裡頭的疲勞素
也就是乳酸
它的濃度也跟著下降
代表靜坐真的能幫助
身心恢復而且趕走疲勞
美國有一個雜誌叫
JAMA Internal Medicine
這個雜誌它說
長期進行正念靜坐的人呢
他們睡眠品質
和自律神經穩定度
都顯著
優於沒有靜坐者
有不少科學研究證實
靜坐可以減輕疼痛
提升專注力和免疫力
還能夠幫助降血壓
舒緩焦慮 改善睡眠
甚至預防憂鬱症
根據美國政府
2007年的調查
美國已經有超過兩千萬人
曾經有打坐的經驗
全球靜坐人口
估計已經達到
2.75億到5億人
打坐好好睡覺
勝過每天吞藥
今晚就來試試
靜坐10到20分鐘
在睡前關燈
放下手機安靜坐著
把月亮掛好
把星星點亮
讓大腦慢慢的沉靜下來
希望你能睡個好覺
清除大腦的毒素
你有靜坐經驗的人
歡迎留言
分享給我你的經驗
兩分鐘睡眠法
成功率96%
要怎麼樣
讓自己快速入睡
今天來教你
一招超神奇的
美國海軍
兩分鐘入睡法
這是二次大戰的時候
美軍為了解決
飛行員失眠問題
所開發的一個技巧
當時的任務壓力很大
飛行員常常睡不好
疲勞出錯
飛行員一出錯
那可是生死交關的問題
所以他們研發出一套
放鬆訓練法
只要兩分鐘之內
就能夠入睡
做法很簡單
閉上眼睛 放鬆下巴
肩膀 手臂 胸口和腿
深呼吸
讓身體沉下去
接著清空腦袋
想像自己漂浮在湖面上
或者默念 不要想
這樣就能幫助你在
兩分鐘之內
快速進入夢鄉
聽你這樣說
我就要睡著了
這催眠效果
看來還真是不錯
這招連戰場上的飛行員
都能在兩分鐘內睡著
經過六週訓練
成功率高達96%
今晚就試試看
熟睡清除大腦廢物
防止失智
許多成功人士
曾推崇短睡
但現在他們開始正視
充足睡眠的重要性
像比爾蓋茲
因為他的父親
罹患阿茲海默的毛病
每天堅持睡滿七小時
不再硬撐
馬斯克也說
睡不到六小時
大腦就會痛得很厲害
睡眠不是浪費時間
而是大腦最重要的
自我清理的時刻
人在深層睡眠的時候
大腦會清除一種叫做
β類澱粉蛋白的廢物
這種蛋白堆積過多
會破壞神經細胞
影響記憶力
甚至可能導致失智症
美國國家衛生院研究發現
健康的成年人
熬夜30小時後
大腦裡面的這種蛋白
就開始堆積
另外有一項
針對8000位
中老年人的研究指出
每晚睡不到六小時的人
失智風險
比睡7.8小時的人
高出30%
睡到飽睡到好
人才會健康 長壽
不只是這樣
美國心臟協會
也將睡眠列為
維持心血管健康的
八大要素之一
充足且良好的睡眠能幫助
修復血管強化免疫力
降低慢性發炎
進而有效預防心血管疾病
睡不好不只是
讓你沒精神
更可能是
危害心臟與大腦健康
睡覺是將疲勞物質
徹底消除的
最簡單高效的恢復法
失眠2大元兇
讓褪黑激素缺貨
睡不好常見的兩大元兇
滑手機滑不停
腦袋一直想
讓褪黑激素分泌不足
越躺越醒
你失眠的時候
都在想什麼呀
想睡覺啊
問題是大腦
像在開深夜直播
交感神經根本沒下班
千萬別硬躺在床上
翻來覆去只會讓
大腦更緊張
刺激交感神經
抑制褪黑激素的分泌
還造成
入睡困難以及淺眠
最後還有一個
難纏的睡眠殺手
我知道我知道
手機啦
手機的藍光
會讓大腦誤以為是白天
褪黑激素不分泌
腦袋持續的開機
越滑就越清醒
熬夜滑手機
提醒你
眼睛千萬
別連續對著手機看太久
專家都說了
那樣手機會沒電
隔天起床呢
你會得到黑輪兩條 哈哈
如果常常這樣看
有危害嗎
哈 熬夜沒什麼了不起的
下輩子注意點就行了
哈哈
感謝最近加入我們頻道的會員
周霽雯
Ching Ching
陳怡吟
JC
WP Huang
有你們的支持
我才能夠繼續做
更好更多的內容
誠摯的邀請你加入會員
成為我們最溫暖的後盾
一起走得更遠
謝謝